Okay. I have to pat myself on the back a little
bit today, uh, but also kind of cry because
this is so horrible. I've been saying for
months, Donald Trump is not married to Fox
News. Fox News didn't support Donald Trump
early in the 2016 Republican primary. In fact,
it was sort of the opposite. Early on. Fox
News was opposed to Donald Trump. They eventually
came around and I've said that they could
bail at any time.
A few months ago, Donald Trump started sending
some sort of light attacks against Fox News.
Shepard Smith was a target. The weekend anchors
on Fox News were targets, and I told you Trump
could abandon fox news and Fox News could
abandon Donald Trump. And if this happens,
watch out because Donald Trump is going to
start promoting an even crazier channel called
o a n one America News, or sometimes it's
o, h n n one American news network. This is
my clip. Okay? From months ago talking about
this, Fox News is not necessarily going to
stick with Trump. They're about profit and
right-wing propaganda. In a general sense,
Trump might be the vehicle for that propaganda,
but he also might not. And just to prepare
you, if Trump and fox have a falling out,
you need to know that Donald Trump's network
of choice is going to become this absolutely
whacked out thing called o a. N the one American
use network or one American use.
Check it out online, but not with kids in
the room and not close to mealtimes because
it is truly it'll, it'll turn your stomach.
Uh, but o h n is where Trump will go if ultimately
he abandons Fox as the propaganda vehicle
of choice. And right on cue yesterday, Donald
Trump tweeting quote, watching fake news,
CNN is better than watching Shepard Smith
the lowest rated show on Fox News. Actually,
whenever possible, I turned to o a n n and
I'm actually getting credit for this one.
My predictions are normally so bad. I'm actually
glad to be getting some credit for this one.
I noticed on the subreddit yesterday, didn't
David predict this with a link to Donald Trump's
tweet? So it's all fun and games and okay,
I got one right finally after getting so many
wrong, but this is a really dangerous channel.
This is even more dangerous actually than
Fox with the exception that it has a much
smaller audience for now, so I guess in a
way that makes it less dangerous.
They for now only have about 380,000 youtube
subscribers. We are just one show that's an
entire network and we have about double that
so it's small for now, but they're growing
quickly. Donald Trump putting the spotlight
on them and saying that it's a good channel
is going to give them significantly more support.
This is a channel that promoted the Seth rich
conspiracy theory. This is a channel that
promoted a conspiracy theory about 17 year
old activist David Hog. They pushed the story
about Hillary Clinton Funding Antifa. This
is, I mean Fox News is bad and it's very well
funded. This is bad and this is what the president
is increasingly promoting. Uh Oh, the OAN
also published smears of George Soros, but
like I probably didn't have to tell you that.
That's almost a given for these channels.
Obviously they're smearing George Soros. It's
almost like a rite of passage. I looked yesterday
after Trump tweeted this at some of the very
toxic pro Trump internet enclaves that I don't
even want to name.
They're thrilled that Donald Trump is now
promoting OAN because as far as they're concerned,
Fox isn't right wing enough for them and it's
not pro Trump enough for them. This is going
to be an insane election season and this also
relates to why we need to be thinking of media
in the context of who are we funding through
our cable subscriptions and in other ways.
Maybe without even knowing it and thinking
about how we can make sure that our dollars,
even the ones that we are offhandedly spending
in a cable subscription aren't going to support
some of these channels espousing views that
we find completely deplorable and disgusting.
Let me know what you think. I'm on Twitter
at d pacman. The show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show. Make sure all to follow me on
twitch at twitch.tv/david Pacman. I ended
up having an impromptu debate with Steven
destiny banella yesterday about TPP, which
we'll be uploading to Facebook later. A lot
of great stuff happening over at twitch.tv/database.